the amount of carbon dioxide co2 in the
atmosphere increases rapidly as we
continue to rely on fossil fuels
the relationship between the elapsed
time t in decades let me highlight that
because that's not a typical unit but in
decades since co2 levels were first
measured and the total amount of co2 in
the atmosphere
so the amount of co2 a of dec sub decade
of t
in parts per million is modeled by the
following function so the amount of co2
as a function of how many decades have
passed is going to be this so t is in
decades in this in this model right over
here complete the following sentence
about the yearly rate of change
the yearly
rate of change and the amount of co2 in
the atmosphere round your answer two
decimal places
every year the amount of co2 in the
atmosphere increases by a factor of if
they said every decade well this would
be pretty straightforward every decade
you increase t by one and so you're
going to multiply by 1.06 again so every
decade you increase by a factor of 1.06
but what about every year and i always
find it helpful to make a bit of a table
so we can really digest things properly
so i'll say t and i'll say a of t
so when t is equal to zero so at the
beginning of our study well 1.06 to the
zero power is going to be one you have
315 parts per million
so what's a year later so a year later
is going to be a tenth of a decade
remember t is in decades so
a year later is
0.1 of a decade
so 0.1 of a decade later what is
what is going to be the amount of carbon
we have well it's going to be 315
times
1.06 to the
to the 0.1
power
and what is that going to be
let's see
if we
so 1.06
to the
so to the
z 0.1
power i didn't have to use extra use of
parentheses there is equal to 1.0058
i'll just stick it with that 1.0058
so this is the same thing as 3.5
times
1.0058 and i should say approximately
equal to i did a little bit of rounding
there
so after another year so now we're at t
equals 0.2 we're at 2 10 of a decade
where we're going to be we're going to
be at 3.5
times 1.06
to the 0.2 which is the same thing
as
3.5
times
1.06 to the 0.1
and then that raised to the second power
so we're going to multiply by this
1.06 to the 10th to the 1 10th power
again or we're going to multiply by
1.0058
a second time another way to think about
it if we want to reformulate this model
in terms of years so per year
of t it's going to be 315 and now our
common ratio wouldn't be 1.06 it'd be
1.06 to the 0.1 power or 1.0058
and then we would raise that now t would
be in years now here it is in decades
and i could say approximately since this
is rounded a little bit
and so every year the amount of co2 in
the atmosphere increases by a factor of
i could say 1.06 to the 0.1 power but if
i'm if i'm rounding my answer to two
decimal places
the well we're going to increase by
1.0058
in fact they should
they increases by a factor of
they should i'm guessing they want more
than two two decimal places well anyway
this this is arguably this this right
over here is five significant digits but
i'll leave it there